farming in Gaza was already an uncertain
way to make a living the Israeli
blockade restricts access to modern
technologies and materials and to wider
markets but coronavirus has made a bad
situation much worse people in Gaza have
lost their jobs and the coronavirus has
completely crippled economic activity
restaurants and kitchens are shut down
wedding parties used to order lots of
chicken and are now canceled almost all
our orders have been cancelled
Hamas Iran administration has begun some
measures to keep the agriculture sector
operating having banned agricultural
exports entirely to ensure supply for
Gaza it's giving livestock farmers a
million dollars worth of vouchers for
animal feed while the whole world is
suffering because of coronavirus
shutdowns we are trying to enhance
resilience of this sector and keep it
working at maximum capacity to guarantee
the food security for people in Gaza but
farmers say it doesn't make up for their
losses
Garza's isolation thanks to the 14 year
long Israeli an Egyptian siege may have
helped keep coronavirus largely out but
it's also damaged the economy
unemployment last year was at 45% more
than half the population lives in
poverty
the additional damage done by the
closure of shops and restaurants means
prices have tumbled since the breakout
of coronavirus the commercial traffic is
so weak because people are afraid it's
added to the economic difficulties of
Gaza citizens people now prefer to save
their money than their pockets
from next week the Agriculture Ministry
is promising to extend support for
vegetable farmers hit by a sudden drop
in demand just weeks ago a one-kilo bag
of onions would cost 55 cents now it's
half that the situation remains as it is
I'll stop and stay at home because I
can't continue being from a pocket and I
will not have enough to feed my children
let her go to the Betty even if the
virus itself is being kept at bay in
Gaza the fear of its long-term economic
effects is spreading
Harry faucet al-jazeera